and I spoke with Governor McMaster in
South Carolina this morning as well last
night I received a request for an
emergency declaration from Governor
McMaster which I approved right away
just as I did for Florida
this allows for immediate Federal
funding
for the state to shelter people and
provide other essential support
by approving it early ahead of the
storm's landfall in South Carolina we
can get supplies in and provide shelter
if necessary
my message to the people of South
Carolina is simple please listen to all
the warnings and directions from local
officials and follow their instructions
and as you all know the situation in
Florida is far more devastating
we're just beginning to see the skill of
that destruction
it's likely to rank among the worst of
the Nations and the worst in the
nation's history
you have all seen the scene on
television homes and property wiped out
it's going to take months years to
rebuild
and our hearts go out to all those folks
whose lives have been absolutely
devastated by this storm
America's heart is literally breaking
just watching people watching on
television I just want the people of
Florida to know we see what you're going
through and we're with you we're going
to do everything we can for you
I say to the rest of Americans just
imagine yourself in that situation Water
Rising walls collapsing streets turn
literally into rivers charter boats on
top of automobiles
watching the home and the community work
so used to work so hard to establish
literally washed away
and folks across the country are now
waiting to hear from parents and
grandparents who live in Florida just
hoping and praying they're okay
in my direction we pre-deployed
the largest team of search and rescue
experts in recent history
because so many of The Rescuers need to
take place now need to be there in place
now in the water now
in the United States Coast Guard has
been deployed as well
six fixed-wing aircraft 18 rescue boats
and Crews 16 Rescue helicopters which
were in the air all day yesterday and
are at it again today
working with the defense department
National Guard state and local First
Responders they've rescued 117 people on
Southwest Florida coast and Fort Myers
and Naples so far
just this morning I spoke personally
with the lieutenant commander of the
Coast Guard Christopher Hooper who was
leading the search and rescue operation
there emphasized this is one fight
everyone working together coast guard
defense department Customs and Border
Patrol Florida Fish and Wildlife local
officials they're doing everything they
can to rescue people he said Mr
President we will not rest at night
until we know they're safe and sound
he talked about how they rescued a 94
year old woman
who had the courage to be hoisted up
onto a helicopter the wind blowing and
as well as a one-month-old baby
not the same time but a one-month-old
baby as well
and so much in between
he also spoke to aviation survival today
I was also spoke to aviation survival
second class technician second class
Zach Lush
who described how difficult the decision
is for people to leave everything and
come to safety I told him how proud of
him I was and thanked him for all the
work he and his coasties are doing to
save lives I'm grateful for the brave
women and men federal state local folks
working so hard they're all working as
one team hear that from the governor as
well as from the federal folks